- Tell me you weren't drinking in there.
- Okay, I don't know what
was going on in there,
but it was definitely not drinking.
- Okay, that's hardly reassuring.
Can you just get it together?
- Yeah.
I just, have you seen that bald guy?
Who is he, he keeps staring at me.
He's really creeping me out.
- That's just the new Air Marshall.
It's his job to stare at things.
Okay, you are so out of it.
What the hell did you do
with that guy last night?
- I didn't do, I stayed
in the hotel, okay?
If you don't believe me, call and ask him.
(audience applauds)
- Hey what's up y'all.
I'm back with Kaley Cuoco
and that was a sneak peak
of her new HBOMax series,
"The Flight Attendant".
Give it up, woo woo!
(audience applauds)
The new show looks fascinating, and scary.
- It's not that funny.
- Yeah, I was gonna say is
this more of a serious thing?
It's on HBO and you wake
up next to a dead person?
- Yes.
- [Kelly] What?
So we, it's based on a book
that I optioned three years ago.
- [Kelly] Okay.
- Yeah, it's about a really
fun-loving, heavy drinking
flight attendant who
travels internationally.
- [Kelly] Apparently yes.
- She goes home with a passenger,
very nice looking passenger
and they have an unforgettable night.
They get black out, and
go back to his hotel.
She doesn't know how she got there
and she wakes up in the
morning, hangover from hell.
And looks over and he's been
brutally murdered next to her
and she has blood on her hands.
And she is in Thailand, by the way.
Left that part out.
They're on an overnight
in Thailand in Bangkok
and she has to get back on her flight
to get back to New York
and she has no idea how this happened.
- Oh my gosh, so that's like more serious.
- It's serious there's some quirkiness,
because I can't not be.
So it was very much written in my voice.
- Kind of dark comedy?
- Yes, exactly.
But yeah, it was pretty serious,
especially as the later episodes go.
It was a full bare, on the ground, tears,
and it was a whole ordeal.
- Are you an avid reader?
I know a lot of actors like to do that.
They like books that they like
and then they like to turn them into,
I know Reese does that a lot.
- Reese does that a lot.
So funny, when I found "Flight Attendant",
I called my team, the first
words out of my mouth were,
"Did Reese get the rights to this book?"
- [Kelly] (laughs)
- Swear to God.
They were like, actually no.
I was like, ahh get in there.
No, I'm not well read, at all, no.
- Oh, I love books.
I love the escape.
I don't like books that scare me.
- No, this was, my team
had been telling me,
they kept saying if you
find an article or a book,
we can adapt it.
And it was never of interest to me.
And then when I saw this book
and I literally read one
sentence and I got this chill
and I said, oh my God, this is a show
and I optioned it and
that was three years ago.
- Isn't it crazy how long it takes?
- Anyone who gets anything done and on TV,
I bow down to you.
It is a miracle.
- It started five years ago, by the way.
If it came out today, it
started five decades ago.
- People think it happened
overnight and they're like wow.
And I'm like, no no
this takes a long time.
So I take my hand off the
anyone that gets anything made
'cause it's not easy.
- Yeah, no it's such a process.
Well, hey this is
actually my favorite thing
and the video is the last
thing we're gonna get to.
So you're husband likes to
post videos of you sleeping?
- Yes.
- [Kelly] And pictures?
- It's creepy and weird, but yes.
- [Kelly] Which is
amazing and here are a few
of his finest Kaley sleeping moments.
(audience laughs)
- So, but wait.
Okay, you showed the videos.
I need the snoring video right now.
'cause this is my favorite.
It makes me so happy.
(loud snoring)
(laughter)
- My husband's Instagram is
devoted to horses, gardening,
and trolling me.
Those are his three favorite things.
- It's like he's a male version
of Chrissy with John Legend.
All she does is troll him.
I feel like that's what he does with you.
- He does.
- And that's my favorite video.
The fact that you're full
on, looking so rock and roll,
but then you go (snort).
- Yeah, I'm out and I can
sleep straight up like that.
He will find me in the
most ridiculous positions
and that's his favorite thing
to get me in the most unflattering.
I think that one he
captioned "Where's her neck?"
- And like look at how
happy your expression is.
- I'm so happy.
- [Kelly] You're having the best dream.
- [Kaley] Wanna be
asleep in that nightshirt
in that cozy bed.
- It's amazing, and you're
totally fine with this.
- Oh, of course I am.
- Which is why I actually love you more.
- [Kaley] Happy as can be right there.
- Because this is amazing.
- Where's her neck?
- [Kelly] And that just means
that you're a fun person.
- [Kaley] You're a fun person.
- [Kelly] Well everybody, "The
Flight Attendant" premieres
with three episodes on
HBOMax this Thanksgiving.
Y'all gotta check it out.